still so young just tomorrow kid right
so uh how young is he do you have any
idea
is he like 13 years old 17 or 20 okay
that you know the young the wrong
how old are you kid you got the name kid
it's a funny name because the older you
get let me tell you it's not going to
work but like
you're like my early early 20s yourself
mid-twenties big guess take a guess come
on
i'm gonna go with 24
25 29 34.
i'm 23. anyway here we have the match
jules versus t-rex and yes i am indeed
23 and i have a name for a kid let's
whatever it's whatever man i'm old
enough to be your father it's crazy
sorry i meant you're old enough to be my
father uh t-rex versus jewels here
eddie gordo versus bob
i hope you're ready
round
one let's see how things are gonna go
t-rex again jules has a lot of
experience when it comes to the any
match-up but you know
eddie is also a very different character
here so let's see how jules is gonna
make it count
yeah a lot of wall pressure right now i
think bob is definitely one of these
characters that's underrated right now
too uh we're seeing more and more bobs
come out and they're putting themselves
on the map uh i don't want to see a
return of second six bob
and ever since texas like he's left the
stain in my mind you know my brain juice
i think about bob like no
no i don't want to see it
right now
bob's into me in second six
i've never been in the competitive side
of the second six so i'm really i want
to know this from you but uh that's for
later so let's see jules though has
t-rex up against the wall against the
counter hit launcher
oh yeah
t-rex god duels back up here gets the
bounce and that should be the round
round three ties it up one a piece foot
really really good showing for t-rex not
a lot of people can get that momentum
back especially when jules takes it in
the first round back to picks up
that was a crazy attempt at running
through that the techno worked out well
i remember one of the weaknesses in this
matchup specifically used to be that if
eddie went relaxed bob's back to have
issues but oh boy never mind it's
flawless
why did i talk about it round four
that's the demonstration
so
good yeah you got to be ready for it
oh my goodness all day
he really did it four times
make it five he's trying to get away
from the wall yeah i try to get away
from the wall kick out of nowhere and
rules then i carry to the wall big time
is coming in and put him in rage yes
can he close it out though t-rex
opportunity gotta watch out for that
rage art when eddie's back to the wall
[Music]
immediately jules again i'm telling you
man jules is someone you would have to
keep your eyes on because this guy been
winning a lot of tournaments not winning
a lot of tournaments but been joining
top eights in recent tournaments and
only recently he did he win uh tatakai
pilipinas which is the most recent
tournament here we had here in uh
in the philippines jules
definitely a scary name to behold
exactly this is first the two here this
is winner semi-finals in the top eight
right now so jules one game away from
making into that top three of course uh
and you know t-rex didn't look terrible
in that game but uh jules is all over
really smothering him ready for the
relax makes up any time that he would go
into relax the back d2 was there uh
other than that the pressure was on
there and obviously we all know eddie
doesn't have a really good sidestep so a
lot of the times when you have that
coming you know like what's that he can
do with bob just continually pressure
you in that situation he's gonna have to
try to force a relaxed mix up
essentially right uh so we'll see what
he tries to bring here in game two but
uh looks like it's an uphill battle for
sure
yeah and that's the tricky part about
this uh match up right eddie has a lot
of stances that can get picked up by bob
with just in just one input alone which
is the back too it's so risky to go for
a hand a handstand mix up or even the
even the relaxed stance because it can
just be negated by the back too so it
it's such super super risky character to
play against bob so do you think a
character switch might happen here
yeah it could be but and i know this is
it's kind of like taboo almost to talk
about nowadays because me and arsenal
have been switching characters so much
but i feel like there are still a lot of
character loyalists out there you know
and
unless you really have that secondary
built up uh it's very very difficult to
switch characters and tournaments i
think you know knee and arsenate there
are obvious exceptions to this rule uh
chicken another player who has a couple
of a few characters you can use but
unless you've been using these
characters like five to ten years you
know until like the top eight top four
of a tournament it's really hard to
bring out your secondaries unless you're
really really comfortable with them but
here we go game two t-rex sticking it
out with eddie gordo
uh and i like what i'm seeing here you
know eddie gordo definitely is a
character that if you're running him in
tournament you probably don't have a
secondary because otherwise you would be
using the secondary
and this is so interesting because t-rex
lost that game one but he didn't go for
an infinite stage which normally you
would see eddie go for you know inflate
stages to move around and you know just
back dash in but this time he chose
island paradise
yeah he used the new back two three
right there a second ago that's
something i want to see him see more out
of eddie like that's definitely one of
the best tools has gotten added but
beautiful jewels with the whip on his
crowd dash one
look at them
that was crazy
and there when he's got that situation
in line for t-rex but no he changes the
position instead this might be bad for
jules though he's so close to that
balcony break
that was terrifying i do not ever want
to play jewels after seeing that
bro jules running through t-rex right
now one round away getting to the top
three of this
looking real tournament working on a
sweep here jules
looking for
once but t-rex is kind of struggling to
find an opening for jules right now the
defense is so good
and you saw just a second ago that
relaxed he tried to go underneath the
pressure but the back two immediately
pushed him out and the get up kick's
gonna counter hit here
walt's wall beautiful conversion smart
stuff from duels all around
look at this
wow
amazing pickup from jules and one more
hit to do with wrong punish from t-rex
and that's a clean 2-0 for jules against
t-rex sends him to the losers bracket
and jules moves on to winners final
exactly top three guaranteed for jules
congratulations sir uh but that as you
called it out clean victory there you
know he looked like he knew everything
about eddie uh was not fazed by the
character choice whatsoever and you know
when you're that comfortable against the
character it doesn't even matter who the
player is you're like i know all the
options for all the tricks you've got
coming at me uh and really that looks
like a really hard character match up uh
specifically you know if you're t-rex
there and you don't have another
character jules is really prepared for
that and to be that prepared against bob
i feel is much harder uh because bob is
so much uh you know so many
how do i say this politely
so much garbage that he can throw at you
uh you know so
nicely done by jules i'm glad to see bob
on the map you know at this stage of
tournament i think as i mentioned
earlier an underrepresented character uh
so it's really nice to see him get this
far
and fun fact about jules is that his
brother pika who is also his coach
pika has been playing eddie
uh a lot especially in his streams he's
been telling people how